Let's go to our caller from the two eight
one area code.
Who's calling today from two eight one?
I mean, yes, it is.
Hey, David.
Longtime fan.
You're actually the first person that got
me into podcasting.
I just wanted to say thank you.
Thank you.
So love it.
I had a question in regards to the piece you
had yesterday in regards to being a hobbyist.
I was curious on your thoughts on how to guess
make the change from a hobbyist into sort
of an activist, because it is very hard to
get it out of the mindset of just simply looking
at the news or information that may suit you
and applying that to actual change outside
of that bubble that a person may put themselves
in.
Well, number one, just asking the question
is important, because a lot of people who
consume political news as entertainment never
ask this question.
They never realize that just like watching
MSNBC doesn't really involve you in politics.
And so I think there's a couple of different
things.
Number one is I recommend everybody at the
macro level don't just consume news.
And in fact, I have a very specific and limited
consumption of the day to day news.
Obviously, I'm producing a show and I'm reacting
to what's happening.
So in doing so, I consume information about
what's going on.
But I actually am focusing more and more of
my time on understanding history and economics
and political philosophy, etc..
So one recommendation I always make is if
you want to take the news and get more involved
in making change, learn about other things
that will better allow you to interpret what's
going on and contextualize it in history and
within the context of different political
systems, et cetera.
But then beyond that, oftentimes what allows
people to go from being political hobbyists
to activists is you can't be an activist on
every issue.
And so figure out what's most important to
you and try to activate there.
So if it's climate and local schools, as an
example, figure out how you can get involved
in wherever you live.
Expanding the infrastructure for transitioning
to clean energy as an example.
Or, you know, I'm just kind of riffing here.
But the idea being you can't just say, well,
I'm a progressive activist and I going to
get involve everything I pay attention to,
I'm now going to get involved.
And it's just not possible.
There's too many things in the world.
So figure out what's most important to you.
And then kind of work backwards and say, OK,
where can I most most effectively and at act
acutely affect some change in these particular
areas?
I think that that's really the best start.
Got it.
So more narrow focus and not being so broad,
we're thinking, because I think that's what
it comes overwhelming at times.
Yeah, a lot of people care about so many different
things that it just becomes too much at once
to focus on your sphere of influence.
Right.
What can I impact?
What can I get involved in right now and start.
There you can still pay attention to everything
else that's going on, but try to narrow your
focus of activism.
Right.
I mean, I think right now, I mean, he's in
Texas and right now awards with outstanding
is what you also talked about how the ever
since that data changed from the CDC to the
Trump administration, it has not been at all
what the numbers have looked like here.
Yes.
In Houston, specifically ending with just
passed a large amount of cases.
So it's very concerning.
I think that's one of the main points of activism
that I'm aiming for, is really trying to be
have be more self aware and spread the actual
truth with what I can within my own abilities.
All right.
Very good.
It sounds like you're you're well on your
way.
I appreciate the phone call.
And please do check back in and let us know
how things ended up going where you ended
up focusing.